two trees in the forest one was crooked
one was straight crimson barking emerald
needles grown day by day
and though they look so different they
enjoy the rain the same side by side
[Music]
a chickadee it's all the mother darkness
on the land spinning blades that came to
visit carried by a man and every other
tree would see them cut down where they
stand by and by
oh can't you see
a crooked tree
[Music]
rather be a crooked tree
[Music]
the perfect trees are driven down the
mountain to the mill we turned them into
toothpicks and 20 bells it seemed the
more the people took the more they
needed still in the end
the crooked trees were left there after
all the work was done
now they go for weeks never witness
anyone
no one left to tell them if they're
growing right or wrong with whispering
oh can't you see
a crooked tree
won't fit into the mail
[Music]
oh i'd machine be a crooked tree
[Music]
do
people say i'm different my way of life
seems strange i took the road less
traveled twists and turns along the way
like the crooked tree i'm growing
stronger day by day as the clouds roll
by
the river never wonders why it flows
around the band a mountain doesn't
question how it rose up from the land so
who you might wish i wasn't just the way
i am who am i can't you see
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'd probably
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Applause]
oh